okay so for those participating in the
livestream
I should explain what this is this is an
internal design review meeting getting
ready for a new version of Wolfram
language I actually don't know what the
agenda precisely is for this meeting but
this is part of our incremental language
development series of meetings
incremental language development is
about adding incremental features to off
mileage so without further ado let's get
started with the first item here which
is something about granular dates what
are we doing with granular dates so one
of the ongoing projects we've been doing
is looking at how we want to integrate
the granular dates that we added an 11-1
into the system further and so we've
looked at a couple of areas where we've
been using granular dates and where the
behavior doesn't really mesh with the
concept so I have basically what's
happened to date interval how is date
interval so date interval we have an
experimental version of it I've mostly
just haven't had time to circle back
entirely because of working on
interpreter caching and the housing
cover discussion by the way so I was
working with Carlos today to streamline
a few things but we have it in the
prototype builds and he's working on a
couple of extra things there are a
couple of domains in interpreter like
school that actually cross a couple of
entity domains and so we're basically
working on those edge cases to make sure
they work well too but you have a pretty
clear sense of what has what the time
delivers for different domains so that
we know what a caching yeah and then
we're working on the the next step sort
of in that is looking at the areas where
we don't have definite time to live so
for things like dates in general that
aren't computed they pretty much have an
infinite time to live you know a date
roberto doesn't actually expire with
time but how we handle some of those
other areas in alpha that the parser
knows what to do with but doesn't
necessarily have TTL information for
that's kind of the next step after we
make sure we have what we know we are we
planning any prefetch mechanism for
interpreter caching
that I haven't talked in detail about I
spoke briefly with Carlo and Jeremy
about it and their sort of questions
about you know what the the scope of all
of that is there's some domains where it
makes a lot of sense with like country
codes there's basically a finite set for
them but for you know arbitrary state
abbreviations we can handle some of the
common cases but beyond that we don't
want to have every permutation of every
possible spelling yeah but what why
don't we plan on prefetching for those
things like state abbreviations and
country abbreviations once we're in a
particular family like the two-letter
state abbreviations for instance right
what's that yeah so in that case there's
50 of them we basically know what the
the standard abbreviations are and we
can go from there
so I think they're more for weird
dependencies of the u.s. who knows yeah
I'm you know I don't know if there's a
two letter abbreviation for Guam
necessarily but yeah there's no okay but
fifty will be a good start mmm okay hey
what let me just ask you since we're
talking about this what is the status of
reflection for the caching for general
entity so for a general entity in in 11
3 we have the basic prefetching there we
also have the synchronous prefetching
that's currently not a documented system
symbol but we're gonna be adding that
and once success gets merged in which is
also finishing up its review now and so
you want to documentation meeting for
what is it cool data to prefetch or
something
yeah yeah so I want to make sure that
success is is totally squared away I
have a follow-up meeting with ETA after
this one and then since that's what
prefetch returns okay what about the
what about spontaneous prefetch in so we
have that as a background download
enabled right now Ben is right now
looking into what we need to do to have
because we talked about I think last
week in the roadmap meeting we talked
about having some sort of status you
know maybe a notebook footer or
something that says downloading a
background data yeah so that's the state
we need is the backend works we just
want to make sure we have a front-end
that you know someone can say stop
downloading background data or don't
download background data okay that
may need some hookup from the front end
group right yeah yeah and that's what
then I checked in with him yesterday and
he was looking into that if I don't hear
anything by the end of the day I'll poke
again okay all right let's go back to
granular dates okay so the first example
here with date range basically what we
noticed is that grant the the standard
practice with data objects is if you
turn them into a moment we go to the
first instant associated with that date
so if you say data object of 2017 it
goes to midnight of January 1st 2017 but
when we look at something like date
range where we have a endpoint that is
also a granular data object it's kind of
funky that if you say give me all of the
weeks from now to 2017 it doesn't know
there aren't any right basically
wouldn't it state object to 2017 should
be a granular date with a chirality of
one year is that correct yes that's
correct but the default scheme we had
would say well it's a granular date of
that's granular to one year but our
standard instantiation goes to the first
moments and basically what we want to do
is in date range we want to go to the
last moment of the implicit year well
hold on if I just do this okay that's
gonna give a nice granular year yeah
totally stupid in date range to go to
the first moment there right in that
argument it should go to the end if it's
the first argument recorded beginning
yep and that's basically what we want to
do in this case the second part of this
which is the next few examples is so in
previous versions we've had a notion of
a week including or a year including
where basically I have a year granular
date but the reference point I give for
it is not actually the beginning of the
year it's sometime inside it and what we
want to do is to canonicalize these so
that if you say give me a date object
for a year that's base ground today it
will actually give you 2017 in its
canonical form and so that's how much
you're saying we think okay so so you're
saying instead of giving you what still
has to be evaluated effectively
including cuz we know I mean you're
including blah blah blah has a canonical
form right wait Daniel Aaliyah of that
whole year yeah it is in the in essence
it is equal to yes my seventeen right I
don't see any reason not to go all the
way in the evaluation mmm-hmm okay
yeah and that's sort of the position we
were getting at right so this becomes
week beginning instead of week including
yes so the canonicalization of a week is
a week beginning such-and-such a date
yes I agree with this completely yeah in
that last example the Sun position was
just another case of when we make the
change to today range it'll propagate so
anything that takes a date range
specification well now you know the
first time you are in eleven two if you
evaluate that you get basically five
data points because it goes to the
beginning of 2018 when we change this
you'll get forty two endpoint data
points because it goes all the way until
the end so is this doing what I would
expect it to do that's telling me the
time between the now instant and the
beginning of the today granular date
that is correct
okay and that's that that will now be
consistent with if I say date range of
today common now comma hour for example
I know what that did so in this case so
this has to do with another bit of
behavior which is that the so for date
range we determined the granularity the
output based on the start date so you
gave a day as an input and then that's
wrong look if you give the granularity
explicitly you want that granularity
right so this is kind of the the tricky
difference between their increments and
their granularities so date range isn't
necessarily taking a granularity it's
saying you know how far do you want
these dates to be between each other so
if you actually maybe protector
granularity so so we have it looks like
you're in prototype so there's a
fourth argument that we were looking at
adding that lets you specify the
granularity so by default it will assume
the granularity of the input so if you
said Howard malakoma our there mm-hmm
then it will degranulation where is that
consistent with the way general
granulation works elsewhere in other
words is if you are specifying do we
have other functions where the
granularity ends up being the last
argument we have finalized other
functions and date range is especially
complicated so there is no other case
which is as complicated as this one
because the granularity has three the
automatic granularity has three places
to look at the three other apartments so
depending on the case there are
different arguments yeah and so the the
counterpoint here with DES range is that
day range is is implicitly a day
granular output so regardless of what
the the step size is or how far apart
the days are it should give you day
increments for each element right date
range so you should be able to replicate
day range by giving date range with a
fourth argument of day yes okay seems
reasonable to me
okay I mean let me just think about that
for a second so the increment there's an
increment in a granularity in the
increment you can sort of think about as
being a quantity so there's a calendar
unit associated with it and there's a
number of stay gnosis the horrifying
thing that you could imagine here is the
function range okay right now it works
like this yeah but you could imagine a
precision granularity is the final
argument here in principle I mean that's
what that would correspond to
I mean not that I think we want to do
that I don't think it's worth it mmm but
it's not inconsistent with the behavior
there in other words that will be
consistent with n of that comma 30 or
something
argument is if we don't want to have a
fourth argument there you can always
explicitly give the granularity you want
by wrapping the first state with eight
objects yeah or you could say these
things here
look the default where are you picking
up the default granularity from from the
start date which is pretty arbitrary it
is I mean I think a better thing to do
would be to pick up the granularity from
the most granule I mean the least
granular the largest granularity
increment largest granularity of the
start and end and increment yeah I I had
done some experimenting with that and it
it gets a little complicated with edge
cases where you have a small increment
but you're taking you know say if the
increment was 40 weeks and you had two
months arguments you may still want to
have in that case it's not obvious that
you necessarily want the granular to be
weeks or months and so it's pretty
auditory to take the granularity from
the first argument I mean the fact you
are giving a you know a an escape valve
of having a fourth argument we can
explicitly specify the granularity is a
fine and good thing mm-hmm
but why the grant so walk me through
this again so what will be an analogous
function I mean if I do range for
example if I do range I think
the granularity if I do this let's say
it's a 38 precision number you know to
ten in steps of 1 or something right so
that's gonna do that now here if I do
this with a precision of you know I may
be about to discover that you're right
okay mm-hmm yeah I think so what range
is doing is it's taking the what range
is doing is it's saying take the first
element keep adding the increment so
what it's doing let's walk through what
it does okay so it says take the first
element and add the increment so
whatever the precision of the increment
is everything beyond the first element
is going to be down to that precision
you see what I'm saying right but but
the quantity has doesn't have
granularity so it's it's the first
object today that has been learnt right
the quantity could be something like a
fortnight for three hours but it is a it
is a granularity in a sense I see what
you're saying I see I see I see I see I
see it's not the same thing as the
increment in range which separately has
a granularity exactly yeah and then the
other sort of thinking along this line
is that range and and date range and day
range typically have you know as long as
the the endpoint is not before the
beginning the start date will always be
the first element of the list and so
that's sort of where we took the notion
that that was sort of another
complementary element to saying well if
you start with today
that is a granularity of day and so if
we want the granular to be consistent
then we can use that as a reference it
is again somewhat arbitrary but it it
was at least consistent through the
framework to say we want to start with
this particular element have you talked
us through decently I mean do you are
you fairly certain of this the thing
about basing it on the first element
yeah I mean we've gone we've been
talking Jose what for two months back
and forth on this to some degree and I
talked with Michael about it last week
too and he was on board okay with with
these changes in the constancy all right
so the things that are coming next from
you a date interval and all the various
temporal logic operators is that correct
we also want to look at for on an 11-2
timescale or next major release we want
to look at some generalizations of the
calendar framework yeah good what kind
of generalizations will fill the
framework so right now we basically have
four named calendars we have Gregorian
Julian Jewish and Islamic and really
there are any number of variations of
any of those calendars if you want to
necessarily have a quote/unquote Western
calendar the date at which you switch
from Julian to Gregorian depends on your
country of origin and different
standards may or may not include a year
zero
so we want to do is sort of figure out
how to parameterize a calendar so that
if I've got a data set that's coming
from NASA and they use an ISO 8601
proleptic Gregorian calendar I can say
okay this is the calendar scheme all of
the dates will then just conform to that
and if I transfer it this is like a time
zone type of deal then you know that you
are specifying in what calendar you want
to you know a date is a date it there's
a definite moment in time right but you
may represent it differently depending
on what your time zone is so to speak
by the way why is there a period in that
time zone so that is that's an artifact
of the way that we we handle time zones
in the kernel but it's actually
something that we're looking at changing
here because historically they've always
been reals but there's no real reason
they need to be well there are time
zones which are five point five or even
quarters I think right there there are
some quarters but the the sort of
canonical versions of GMT minus five
doesn't necessarily need to be no we
basically know it's an integer offset
right then we should make it that it
looks stupid
okay go ahead another interesting
generalization of the calendar argument
is to support also something like
absolute time and then we can put a
number in the first argument and then we
have a nice representation for an
absolute time rather than having it as a
pair number yeah that's nice the other
thing I would assume is that there are
all these crazy calendars that involve
you know business days and all this kind
of stuff right yeah and they're the way
do we we do have all of the curated
calendars from wolf alpha in here don't
we we we have the majority of them
there's a little bit of a translation
between the two but we periodically run
basically a job that grabs the data from
Wolfram Alpha and then turns it into our
holiday calendar schedule there's still
sort of the notion of like I think we
talked about special day data at one
point where like pi day isn't really a
holiday on any financial X
but you may want to look up different
significant days with different
parameters and that's the curation task
that Alan and they believe the the
Peruvian group have been working on okay
okay so question I mean like if we
wanted to put our company holiday
calendar in here how would we do it so
the existing holiday calendar system has
a way to specify a custom holiday
calendar using pure functions it's
something that existed before I started
looking at the date framework and I'm
pretty sure is something we need to
update we've talked briefly in the past
about having some sort of hat either
pattern language or some sort of
selection criteria to specify look I
mean that the main main issue is you're
gonna want something like saying how
many working days are there for our
company between then then right right
and so you could also imagine a company
that has you know I don't know like it
has production you know it has
operations staff that have different
holidays from I don't know the
development staff or something right and
so in general you could say how many
operations working days are there from
here to here so in a sense we're going
to want a key the notion of what um
let's see I mean you know a day
what we really wanted gonna want to do
is label days right a day is a working
day and operations working day are this
kind of dare that kind of day I would
think I mean we want to essentially
color the days in a particular you know
for all time but there can be a pattern
based on a particular year mm-hmm you
know we want to color the days in a year
based on whether they are to be
considered working days or not working
days etc mm-hmm that would be my I
thought about what we want to do with
the calendar thing and um because the
main issue is is it a I mean another
thing you know is it is it a how many
days when there are banks open is it
between this something anyway that will
be my thought about this but I guess
that's a separate discussion that would
be my initial suggestion for how to do
that rather than go ahead maybe I was
gonna say okay I mean that I've been
thinking a little bit about having some
sort of like Holland a calendar object
or some way that you can you know I
could create this is the way this is the
scheme we use for holiday calendars at
the wolfram office in Champaign this is
the one for the Wolfram office in
Britain and then I can reference and say
days run between this in that sounds
reasonable okay i it go so would be
useful even in our own company that
would be useful mm-hmm okay let's go to
our next item if we can does that hum
yes we have a newer version than this
okay so I should update yes please and
the one other date and time project
we're looking at a little not
immediately it'll probably be after data
intervals is looking at various ways to
handle time systems in in some way
that's dependent on our our
parameterised calendar framework but the
idea I mean by time system means the UTC
one versus UTC we need that for the
astronomy stuff right exactly
excellent no that's horrifying because
that's going to be an actual data feed
of the you know difference of UTM versus
UTC versus whatever else
and how you handle leap seconds and
different systems that sort of deals
with the the you know precisely what
moment is this and how do we transfer
between right I mean that's the our log
of what we did pretty carefully for
geodesy we have not yet done for time
exactly yes in in a sense calendars are
like projections and time systems are
like they do yes but there are only one
dimensional which probably makes them
easier yes and they don't have the
topology of the sphere right presumably
who's to know exactly who knows whether
the universe is pretty early right um of
course what do we do I mean if we
actually want to support cosmological
times are we going to get messed up with
some of that stuff what what we okay
this is our one science minute here
science moment here in a general
sophistic framework do we have any hope
of being able to deal with these time
systems in a reasonable way well
actually we do so there are several
times which are centered at different
places like the surface of the earth the
center of the earth or the center of the
solar system the very center of the
solar system and there are formulas to
relate them so I am indeed planning to -
what about gravitational redshift and
stuff like this well that's a bit more
complicated because it will depend on
having the notion of speed of objects
not just dead positions so also I mean
it's gonna be the full metric tensor
it's gonna be two things it's gonna be
the full metric tensor of position etc
yeah so it's it depends how far we want
to go so we can have just the name
systems and the name will specify
whether you are on the surface of the
earth or at the center of the earth etc
well we can have the freedom of
specifying any place in in the solar
system say and then we will have to
handle well I think for the time being
we'll just deal with the name systems
exactly yes there okay
alright should we move on here yeah so
this function is ready we have completed
the changes that we discussed in the
last meeting all the three also as we
discussed them we have an example on
unfortunately this is not in index
kernel yet so I'm afraid you cannot use
it but we have an example the linking to
the d-brane graph and explaining how one
gets the sequence from the crafts and
properties and relations what do you
have in sorry yeah its properties in the
PDF it's there oh what a mess it's like
it's a joint treatment no but isn't the
de bruyne graph
just
the thing you get by going pairwise yes
yes it is so here we are constructing
the same sequences in order to compare
it a bit below in the manipulated
expression because you are going to come
oh this is way over complicated if I
might say so I think come on just show
the basic case look just show the de
Bruyne sequence do the partition do the
overlapping partitions and make the
graph just to show that this structure
and then just do the labels based on
lists rather than strings but but the
problem is that it's not just following
the 0 0 2 so it we have to focus on the
edges and next and and link the name of
one vertex with their last digit of the
next one it's it is not true look look
it's this right it's this thing or my
even doing here
so this will be in the lens of
solicitous subsequences will be reached
in this example okay but I mean the
point is that the de boigne graph is
you've got a sequence and you are saying
the transition from this sequence to
that sequence is made by adding a one
edge right exactly yes yes but if I
understand correctly the edge is
determined by the last digit is fine now
it is know of each one of these right so
the edge the edge label which you don't
necessarily have to give right I mean
this is each one of these is I mean we
could just say block map if I'm not
mistaken I never use block map but isn't
it this am I wrong I forget how block
map works how does block map work
overlap okay great
blahhh wasn't that work
Oh does it have I see it's probably got
happy you need to start with your
regional list no no I don't think so I
think this is exactly the right thing
I doesn't have the right number of edges
for a deploying drove I don't think and
that is definitely not right the number
of subsequences will correspond to the
number of edges
yeah the construction is not as simple
as one would wish you're right you're
right because the de Bruyne the way to
construct the de bruyne graph is to just
take all the tuples and for each tuple
join it to the tuple which has for each
of the tuples right so if I go to poles
we don't need to do this I mean if I if
I do this right then each tuple is
joined to the tuple that has the two
differing you know that's the that's the
thing with a shift with a one or a zero
added with the shift yes we have vertex
vertices with two digits and then with
the edge we add one digit either zero or
one right okay so but anyway the
ordering that we have here is consistent
with the ordering and oh boy in our to
Brian graph is that correct yes yes okay
turns of the point sequence
why isn't
further Bryant sequence because we have
many sequences for given input why this
correspond to all the possible ordering
of part of the sub sequences that you
can do the number is actually quite an
artist it's the second note
hmm gives a de bruyne sequence on the
elements just to make it a little bit
more
okay okay um don't we want to reference
real digits here um don't we want to
reference the whatever thing in real
digits gives you because isn't the isn't
the um isn't that the maximal length
sequence don't you get these in like if
I'm not mistaken it's it's real digits
or endearing digits
yeah we're thinking of digits maybe no
I'm thinking of real digits right I'm
thinking of real digits of like 1/7 if
I'm not mistaken isn't that thing there
in binary related to the de boigne
sequence am i completely confused in
order to in order to not repeat right in
a in a in a in a rational you know in a
fraction right don't you have to have
maybe I'm completely confused
they look um so I'm not sure how it is
raised to real districts yes it may be
your link that's I see so you're
thinking that this could be the de
bruyne sequence of something else
let's see what is this
now that's something utterly wait a
minute
that's something utterly bizarre and
different
you
yes that construction is the one that
will imitate it in the previous example
okay all right I don't know what I'm
talking about then fine okay um did you
do backlinks of all these things not yet
and it's this knitted do we want to do
that right now or do we want to keep
going with other stuff now let's go on
with other things okay but we need to
remember to do this is it we can do it
in connection with some other ones okay
yeah okay all right all thank you yes so
this is an interesting suggestion of a
function I have my my suggestion at the
end but okay all same Q of X bar comma
half yes yes okay is the ABCD
exactly but in general like all true we
would accept any hat right
all same bye mm-hmm
basically returns true if those things
are all the same according to that
criterion exactly so we first map F over
them and then we'll compare their selves
right and you want the same test which
is the analog of what happens for Union
which seems reasonable to me
because that that's a rare case that you
want to do they you want to change the
same test yeah exactly
yes so sometimes we will want equal for
example to allow for tolerances and
things like that
well what is the default is the default
same Q it's almost thank you
for there is a difference for finite
precision numbers it's a bit more strict
than then thank you okay okay I did and
and yeah it will be like all two with a
level specification did you did you
start documenting this are we happy with
the name well that's one of the main
decisions to make here do you see the
other side yes use by other people
they're like saying by Q but I don't
think it should be a q function because
you don't use equal then it will not
return true right same thing as all do
so I agree that that all true has its
has its function in there right it has a
test so all true is expression comma
test right which is which is the analog
of this because this is oh I see I see I
see I see so that that is checking that
they are all true mm-hmm whereas this
has to have a by in it because it is
applying the function first and then by
that function are they all same exactly
it's a bit like or thorn on tool tool in
a sense we could think of a
generalization of all to that handles
both cases but it would get complicated
sure right
it seems reasonable to me seems pretty
good to me
should we usually put in a stub page for
it yeah thanks um do you think we would
need an awl and sing by it's a bit
strange but what's that all unsane in
the same way that we have sent you an
insane McHugh yeah I understand what
you're saying I think that's really
pretty obscure
hmm I mean it's basically all distinct
by this criterion exactly I don't know
well we can start with that with this
one and if users ask for the other one
so this would be an F how do we do this
for something like take largest bite we
call it f yeah I think so okay tests
whether that's whether all the F of e
sub I are the same
whether all the e sub I are the same
after applying F and this is more
precise okay you really want to level
Spector yes I think so it will be common
that we want to check all elements of an
array for example oh good point
is there an all version for the level
spec or what do you mean well I mean how
how far down okay so this has a level
spec okay
at level at that level at the specified
level yes and is it desks for converse
oh why don't you
tests whether
like spur no we don't want to say that
because you know we want to say compares
parts of export because that's right
because it's got the F in there right
thanks
okay hmm
so now we say all same by an option same
test hmm well let's see how do we do
that in Union for example that's a
reasonable way to do it yep okay
I've expert comma F same two comma dot
dot same test arrow test so what are we
going to say applies
you know what this
the right way to do this I think yeah
way to do it is to is to just give this
for the for the single list case mm-hmm
applies test to each pair of F II I to
determine okay yep and then we go to say
somewhere the the default for the same
test yes is automatic that can you again
well
missing what it is in Union actually I
guess it's easy it's in examples okay
all right what should this point to this
should point to all true is that true
yes I would say same queue and all true
possibly equal and what else think the
union may also be useful
fair enough
all right okay that's not good okay
let's move on I mean we got to knit this
obviously and so on later but but that's
a good start for this okay let's talk
about Auto flatten which i think is
gonna be a little bit more difficult to
discuss yes I don't understand what the
suggestion is here okay
the issue is yeah I know it's because I
hate sequence because I think sequences
semantics is just a total mess so this
is a bit like nothing which is covering
an easier case yes but is it equivalent
to a sequence or procedure restricted
case subsequence that's a good question
because I don't really know what
sequence does because they don't know
how far sequence melts if you understand
what I'm saying
um so for example I have no idea whether
if I do let's try it
um okay so that case does that alright
what happens if I sequence the sequence
I don't like the fact the sequence
doesn't contain okay don't really fully
understand well I guess that the inner
sequence just splices itself into the
outer sequence is it Broly yes because
the fact that the first sequence
survives is because rule is whole
sequence yeah the only way I can do this
if I have a list here is to say sequence
at at XYZ right which is definitely into
the grotesque it's been that way since
forever
yeah I know I know I know I just don't
think it's a very beautiful I mean I
think we're very happy with nothing
aren't we I mean as opposed to there's a
different purpose or a related purpose
or one of sequences purposes and we are
happy with it but sequin still has its
use in exactly the way that you show it
I understand but the question is can we
get rid of that use as well and stamp
out sequence whenever we can um to me
the main advantage of nothing is that it
survives through things that are not
sequence hold sure but it survives
through everything other the only place
where it lives okay so look the idea of
this Auto flatten would be that Auto
flatten is to splicing as nothing is to
having it go away completely this what
I'm saying so in other words what I
would imagine is that the only place
just like nothing you know if I do this
okay I get nothing there if I do F of a
B nothing D I don't get then nothing
just sits there the pure list operation
hmm and so the idea would be to have
this be a similar Auto melting list
operation okay so that roughly what it
would do is if we say ABC you know I'm
this I don't like this word I don't like
the world at all
Auto flatten X Y D right oops
but that would just you know that would
be an inside-out I'm going to melt
myself away and put those things into
splice those things into the list what
are some good words that this
I think this is a useful operation
couldn't in that sir so that then you
can replace this is a way of doing a
sequence replacement right well you just
say that the typical case would be ABCD
you know slash a you know slash dots C
goes to list XY right now that will do
this but if I say C goes to Auto splice
to XY not that that's the right word um
that will splice it in seems useful to
me and these would only work in lists as
what would be just like nothing mm-hmm
what would it be called I mean what is
it doing it's splicing it's flattening
it's Auto flattening or every it's got a
note flatten out the problem is flatten
out I understand it's it's a flattened
above and flatten out I mean you know
strangely this is a in a sense the a log
of nothing is not a list so to speak
also a very very bad name but you
understand what I'm saying it's a list
that is not a list
it is that's horrifying horrifying
horrifying um that's what we asked if
anybody is watching this live stream
maybe somebody has a brilliant idea out
there in splice
something like that isn't bad what what
are some words like splice
I mean the problem is it wants to say
Auto splice it's a it's a it's a
splicing or something note about head
nursing only thing head what called
nothing had no scene yeah it was record
like nothing but this is DBA just for
the head strange maybe it's very very
very decapitate right um I mean there
are many words even my trusty thesaurus
is telling me um for you know yeah unite
interlace graft in twine the problem is
what
what are we calling I mean what is the
[Music]
okay that's about this there is a good
name for this we just don't know what it
is yet
um and it might even have the word list
start and what about nothing as a head
and so we're using nothing stand
you
that's really weird that's really weird
but this already valuates know this this
one - nothing
yes I'd say why does it do that
no idea
good answer why the heck does it do that
that documented oh wow
why does it do that
why is it that we must have had a good
reason for doing that yeah looks quite
aggressive
I didn't write it eats anything
why is it doing that Oh
that's why it's doing it look that's
cool I don't even know that worked right
see that yeah yeah that's cool um but
not I see so it's a view of sequences as
well but making the things inside
disappear in the process yes suggesting
had dissolved yeah I was thinking like
it's almost like you're injecting it
like it's it's not really an insertion
but you're kind of sticking it in and
it'll fall into place
so like implant it's maybe a little
implantable yeah it's very whimsical
it's remarkable there's so many words
for a concept like this
I mean my mild preference would be I
don't really like it list spliced
I don't really like that I don't really
like the words splice cuz we've you know
we've used it for some ancient purpose
um what's nice about nothing is that
it's a noun that just you know it turns
into nothing it does so what this is is
you know it's an unpeeled list it really
unpeel zit self and no I I don't think
we can use unpeel
[Music]
so the term we've got is flattened which
will be the outer from the outside what
we'd be doing is flattening and the
attribute flat would do this right this
is a local version of the attribute flat
and I don't really like something like
list flat um
as flat totally obscure totally
absolutely obscure um
some kind of gnarnia typed word or
something I don't know um
no doesn't make it well okay so look I
think the concept is good we just need a
name um we're about to run out of time
let's just take a quick look at the
curry thing we're gonna have to return
to this and and discuss its name um
flood and well that's an interesting
idea that's not totally stupid
why don't we implement it with that name
see how it works
I mean flattened in would be but
flattened it's not totally silly because
it gives a sense of the flattened
operation which we want to give yeah
it's no
aligned with the other flat alright it
was great it's a winner let's implement
it like that hope that it sticks and
here I mean this is just great head
compose was finally put to put to rest
after you know at least 25 years of of
distinguished but invisible service ok
what is this yeah so so there are two
parts here one is the suggestion of
changing the name for our function curry
which we discussed and the other one
which I looked it seems more interesting
to me is the idea of the partial
evaluation because our current current
curry function does not do anything
until it gets all the arguments it works
yes when Carlo here was suggesting that
curry could kind of convert itself into
a nested function which I don't like
very much
no I mean record whether the name is
gonna be can I have it to invent module
names for itself
yes or we could do some sort of hash mr.
- but can you do you guarantee to be
able to do that I don't think you can no
you cannot do a nested hash look at this
case it can't do it with hash this is
the famous whatever it is a toe
reduction of lambda calculus is on crazy
thing like that right
you can't do that well it needs to
locally know which I know yeah do it I
mean this is a crazy crazy thing this is
actually our friend de Bruyne the
aforementioned had the scheme for
renumber and relabeling lambda
expressions yes yes right but so
this particular thing of unravelling you
know into actual functions is
interesting but I think it's a different
operation
yeah you're right it is that this has
the ability of eating one at a time
which I don't know what it's used for
well I mean but what well it would be
something like a curry expand or
something of f comma three is is a turn
the curry into yeah let me think about
this for a second okay but anyway what
what what is the suggestion about curry
up here
I think it is that in the last meeting
you were not sure that curry was still
the proper name for our different yeah
and so I think Chevy I was just trying
to proposal now so this would be
something which since we have this head
composed which is a reverse reverse
function of current Curie maybe we could
go with head decompose or compose head
glogg oh yeah claw go I mean it's pretty
obscure let's remind ourselves what on
earth so head compose has been
deprecated right yes deprecated through
utter failure to be used is that correct
well until now we have have many
functions that have multiple birth of
products so I mean in the last run what
is our modern analog of head compose is
there a modern analog of head compose or
is it that we just decide it was useless
well we have discussed folding construct
folding construct yeah yes we do I mean
the equivalent of construct right now is
composed which is also deprecated
yeah I understand
by the way do we do have construct
coming in the next version right yes
then he has now book was for it okay
so what
folding constructor folding what yes do
fold of compose and analyst
okay
how's that different from curry constant
you friend
well I mean isn't that a form of Korean
yeah I accept the going from the list to
that composed form is not something that
curry function does okay right the curry
function is doing it the other way round
the curry function is taking a thing
like that and it's turning it into it's
going the opposite way here this is an
uncurl you know okay I'm curry alright
so is that something that we also want
for I think we want this I mean look I
think I think the operations that we're
trying to deal with are the curry
operation
you
thing that looks like this to actual
arguments right yes so a will be the
curry the curry object curry with a
single pair of brackets F comma to say
yes
can we inventory so I think we've got
some other operations here that are in
the uncurl kind of department and so on
so we've got two different things here
one is the expansion of a Curie
something to an explicit lambda
expression and to an explicit explicit
collection of lambda expressions right
yep the other is the the construction of
the opposite two currying that is going
from a sequence to a series of
applications
I think there's a brilliant name for
curry that isn't curry
okay we can look at I do like curry
cause you are I mean
well for the people who will want to use
it I think they will know because this
is called covering there is even a
Wikipedia page for covering no I
understand that but but let me let me
let me argue against that okay mm-hm
there is a certain class of people who
right now what this operation appears to
us utterly obscure okay so let me give
you an example we could have named fold
what is it beta reduction or something I
forget what that that actual thing is
called
as it turns out that name fold I gave it
the same name as it would ended up being
given in ml I think and Haskell
eventually if I remember correctly just
kind of interesting because I don't you
know I definitely didn't get it from
them
they might have gotten it from me I
don't know but I think it was more or
less the same time but so it was an
operation where the official name in the
literature was I think beta reduction
okay I was some kind of beta something
or other thing I thank goodness we
didn't call it that because nobody would
have ever used it or to have used it it
would look like we're diving deep into
theoretical computer science
right so right now at the time okay so
the fold operation just to be clear that
operation was I knew about that
operation because it was being used in
parallel computation stuff okay and it
was being used in a way that was fairly
I don't know I mean it also existed in
APL actually I think in some form I'm
not sure what the Bernie case it had a
technical name if we can name Kareem on
technically it has a hope you know in
five to ten years of being used more
generally
if we name it
like we didn't call function lambda and
which was you know in modern times right
people have heard of lambdas maybe maybe
some people have but you know if you
called it lambda right now right if we
call function lambda then for our
elementary users you can guarantee
there's a whole story about why is it
called lambda whereas with the name
function it's like well okay it's a it's
some kind of anonymous pure function II
thing so it's called function it's the
function function so I mean I think we
want to look for a name that is more
along the lines of function or fold than
along the lines of something that
requires a knowledge of the history of
theoretical computer science I mean in
other words you know the other point of
view is that it's a special function of
function functional programming like a
Bessel function and it was you know
arguably
right I mean arguably sometimes where
we've tried to genera size a name oh I
don't know like famously product log
which was had bad history anyway um you
know it's not clear that was a good
there was a particularly good name so I
I'm not certain but I think I think we
should we owe it to this function to not
simply give it a historical name
okay but I don't know what it really is
and I'd like to can you write up what
these three cases that we know of right
now and also all the ambient functions
construct composition all this kind of
thing because all of those you know
construct and composition are both
perfectly nice you know generally
understandable things I mean even to a
typical mathematician um the
yes
from Twitter's pointing out that in ml
uncarrier will be the verb to poll oh
gosh yes well that's true right because
it's going from a curried form to a list
e to Polly form um fold is cool reduce
yes that's true in other languages and
non-technical version of curry function
application list hmm function
application see the I don't know quite
what that means I mean that's a
there is some kind of notion of
something like I mean fortunately this
isn't a list for us it's a sequence of
arguments sequence
function sequence neither of those work
I mean this notion of of successive I
mean maybe there's some way we can do
something based on construct construct
has two arguments right multiple works
what does it do it I'm sorry is it f of
X comma Y if it's yes arguments yes well
so I mean one possibility I mean okay so
there's that this is perhaps crazy but I
mean there's definitely yeah this is
crazy
there's things like fold construct which
would be which is the equivalent of head
compose that's kind of crazy kind of
nuts actually how's that different from
the example right above it the fold of
compose it's no different I mean except
that that would be yes it's no different
from that so that's what fold construct
would would effectively be that fold of
compose yeah I'd be this okay and what
does curry do in this situation does the
exact opposite opposite okay it unpacks
this into because curry okay what point
is when we say curry we mean the thing
that is has the curry wrapped around it
is is the thing that is curried so to
speak so that it is in some sense the
operation of taking that and unpacking
it as an uncorroborated does that make
sense is curry implemented anywhere is
this implemented in the external yes it
is so okay so if I say curry of F comma
3 X Y what am I doing here okay
that's what I get there right so that
means this is the curried form of F okay
all right that's what that means but it
is one a none technical a syntactic term
for
this would be unbreaking that's
interesting so it's interesting that
that maybe there's a I mean okay so but
actually that's not the right thing
right that's unbreak it that's not the
thing itself isn't unbreak --it it is
that operation is unbreaking which is
otherwise known as uncaring but the
thing itself is a curried is a thing
which has been curried which is why it
uncovers itself when it applies to
arguments see what I'm saying yeah
well we could have multi bracket what
so following Danny's idea of using
bracket what we are doing is converting
F into a version that expects multiple
brackets the other
we have out in the world of in our world
a sub value yeah but in fact this isn't
the suburbs anyway I got to go to a
different meeting but okay we still
haven't solved this curry curry naming
problem let's let's write down the
ambient functions and try and and if you
can send those out and let's try and
have a think about that okay okay do I
need to send this agenda back to Sushma
here yeah you can send that to me okay I
listen which is suggesting apply
unfortunately apply means something
apply for what it's worth means this
operation but something like melt for
what for the thing that is melting away
brackets but it isn't that's the whole
point the whole problem is this is not
the outer operation look there will be
one thing that would take an operation
we don't have actually in which we could
have to take that and explicitly turn
that into f of X comma a comma B comma C
that is another operation that we could
have right which we probably should have
we don't have that operation we've never
really needed that operation this is a
thing that automatically whatever that
operation is called you know this is
like our flattened versus flattened yeah
it's a black okay I mean you know
conceivably that could be called bracket
flatten of f of whatever and and that
could be you know that would conceivably
be I don't know if it's a good idea goes
to f of X a B right and that then this
could be in a much more complicated name
because you know that would be hardly a
thing that would be attractive for
people to use a bracket flattening of
this bracket flattened F comma three but
that's a horribly complicated name
but this is a quite an interesting
operation it seems to me you don't
believe we have right now I mean we have
those very old operations operating
through from you know 30 years ago that
have rarely been used sadly but maybe
maybe they are about to make a
Renaissance as we you know as as we as
we look at more Korea both ings maybe
all those operations have been rather
obscure will come back to life alright
let's wrap it up ok thanks a lot guys